next question today from the audience
hey David what would happen if Donald
Trump were to not accept a primary or
general election defeat and try to
declare himself as dictator listen I I
understand that people point to Donald
Trump having said look at what the
Chinese President did removing term
limits for himself that's something
maybe we could look at in the future
there are these sort of little data
points that we could look at when it
when it comes to Trump trying to remain
in power but I think it's important in
the same way that when the right said
Obama is going to declare martial law
and try to suspend the 2016 election and
remain in power indefinitely or whatever
there was nothing backing up that that
was something President Obama was even
considering doing it was just bogus
conspiracy talk and along the same lines
I think that we shouldn't really
entertain this stuff in a serious manner
with Donald Trump either because as
depraved as the Republican Party has
been as much as they've stood aside and
allowed Donald Trump to get away with so
much day after day after day I don't see
any path to Republicans or Democrats
standing by and allowing even the
possibility of Donald Trump doing
something like this if Donald Trump is
primary and he loses yes he will make
all sorts of allegations I just don't
see any way that they succeed in holding
up the results of a trump loss and the
primary if that were to happen if Donald
Trump loses the 2020 general election
and alleges that there are
irregularities or whatever else I just
don't see any way in which politically
it's allowed to happen and even if
Donald Trump attempted whatever kind of
funny business you can imagine I don't
think he has quote the generals as he
likes to say to back him up and
ultimately I I think that if Donald
Trump were to try to retain power
despite a loss it would it would sort of
depend on the military to go along with
it and I just don't see it because
despite the
president being the commander-in-chief
of the military we've seen the generals
speak out when they see Trump doing his
nonsense and doing things that he
shouldn't be doing so I just don't think
it there's any way that it happens I
don't even think it's really a worthy
thing to go into too much because then
we start to sound sort of like the
people who are saying Obama will declare
martial law if I'm wrong if I'm missing
something let me know and I'll
reconsider